- Welcome back.
I've got Lauren Graham here give it up.
(audience cheering)
Her show is called
The Mighty Ducks Game Changers.
It's on Disney Plus
you should check it out
or you're a loser.
And because I liked the show so much,
it's time for a game called
Mighty Ducks or Mediocre Ducks.
(game show music)
All right well we need a host.
So Lord are you free?
- [Lord] As a bird Kelly.
Actually maybe birds are as free as me
after all I created them
and you and pretty much everything.
- You did a good job
when you created me man.
- [Lord] Yes I did.
(laughs loudly)
- All right we'll say
hello to the almighty.
- Hi.
- [Lord] Hey how you doing girl,
remember we was in Evan Almighty together.
- Yes yes.
I love your work.
- [Lord] Yeah.
Anyway.
(laughing)
- Oh my gosh.
- So what's up with the game?
- [Lord] Well in this game,
I'm gonna read a plot line or quote.
Now if what I said was from Lauren's show
you will buzz in and say Mighty Ducks.
But if it was not from her show
you will buzz in and say Mediocre Ducks.
Because not all ducks were created equal.
(audience laughing)
Now Kelly you're gon be playing
for the left wing of the audience.
- Wow!
(audience cheering)
- [Lord] And Lauren you gon be playing
for the right wing.
- Nice okay.
- [Lord] And the winner will give her side
a very very cool prize.
Now there is one more rule
and perhaps the most
important you gotta wait
until I'm done reading to hit your button.
- Oh okay.
- [Lord] I'm looking at you Kelly.
- I was gonna say I know that was for me.
Okay fine.
- [Lord] Okay here we go.
Here's the first question.
- Okay.
- [Lord] This show or
movie involved ducks using
an object called the Black Disc of Death.
(buzzer ringing)
That's you.
That's my that's that was her.
That was Mighty Ducks Game Changer.
(buzzer ringing)
Yes!
- [Lord] That is correct.
- I was like that was
her that said it okay.
- [Lord] That is what Lauren's character
called the puck.
- I can't believe I beat
you to your own line.
(laughs loudly)
- [Lord] Okay Kelly you got one point.
- This feels good.
- [Lord] Here's question
two calm down girl.
Now rein it in.
- Okay.
Okay
- I see how this is gonna go.
- [Lord] Question two.
- Okay.
- [Lord] This show or movie,
had an old duck named after a gin,
who liked to eat cake leftover
from kid's birthday parties.
(screaming)
- I had to wait until I was done.
- Mighty Ducks.
(buzzer ringing)
- [Lord] It is mighty ducks.
And of course that's Gordon Bombay,
played by the adorable Emilio Estefez.
- He is so cute I love him.
I love him.
(giggling)
- [Lord] Question number three.
This duck filled show
or movie had a character
who said rather prophetically I might add
and I know prophets said,
today I have a feeling you're going
to fall down a lot.
(buzzer ringing)
- Damn.
- I think that's also mighty ducks.
- It's you.
- [Lord] It is mighty ducks.
And you said it.
You're the one who said it.
- I'm just my main flex
is here's the thing,
you know what's throwing me off?
And I think you did this rule on purpose
it's throwing me off because I have
to keep waiting on you to finish
your long-winded ways okay.
- Excuses excuses.
- Ugh!
- [Lord] Well that doesn't change the fact
that Lauren is in the lead.
- Oh come on okay okay.
- [Lord] Here's the next one.
This show or movie had a duck
who said every duck has his limit
and you scum have pushed me over the line.
- What?
(buzzer ringing)
- It's not I didn't say that.
That's mediocre duck.
- [Lord] It is mediocre ducks.
- What's that?
- [Lord] And now just to
upset Kelly even more,
I'm going to offer you a bonus point
- Oh she don know.
- [Lord] With this question.
This is for you Lauren.
- Okay.
- [Lord] For a bonus point,
do you know the name of that duck?
- Daffy?
(laughing)
(buzzer ringing)
- [Lord] I'm sorry.
We were looking for Howard the duck.
That was the movie Howard the Duck.
- Now that's a throwback Lord.
- [Lord] Yes.
Here's the next one.
This show or movie involved a duck
that lived in a New York city apartment
with roommates that included a chick,
a Joey,
and a Chandler.
(buzzer ringing)
- Friends.
I don't know why I didn't say it.
(laughing)
Yes.
(buzzer ringing)
- [Lord] Mediocre Ducks.
- Oh Mediocre Ducks.
- [Lord] And Friends is correct.
- Oh you said Chandler.
- Yeah.
- [Lord] You got it.
That's right.
- They had a duck?
- They had a duck.
- [Lord] There was a duck involved.
- Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah.
- [Lord] So technically it counts.
- And a monkey?
- [Lord] Sure why not?
- Yeah.
- I won.
- No.
- [Lord] Here's your next question.
- Okay.
- [Lord] This show or
movie involved a plot
to sneak into a building
to heist some of the sticks
and blades from a lost room
owned by a bunch of ducks.
(buzzer ringing)
- Yes!
That's you.
- I did.
- That was Mighty Ducks Game Changer.
- [Lord] That's correct.
- They were going to the lost and found.
- [Lord] That's right.
Lauren and her team.
- And then the one the cute one
just so you know distracted the lady.
I watch the show.
(laughing)
- [Lord] I'm just.
(duck quacking)
- Oh that quack that quack bell means,
that this is the last question.
- Wait oh but okay is it.
- [Lord] And this one is worth five bills.
So whatever you do,
don't duck it up.
(audience laughing)
- Oh.
- [Lord] That's a little God joke.
That's a God joke for you.
Kinda like the duck-billed Platypus.
Okay.
- Oh my God.
- [Lord] Here's the last one.
In this show or movie
a mama duck went into the
middle of a cold pond,
yelled at a bunch of other ducks,
and then went home and ate cheese puffs.
(buzzer ringing)
- That's you.
That was you and you were angry
cause of the rude moms and dads.
That's Mighty Ducks Game Changers.
- [Lord] That is correct.
- Woo!
(audience cheering)
- [Lord] The winner is Kelly.
This is unbelievable.
It's an upset.
- You know for a minute
I was like Gilmore girls?
I didn't eat cheese puffs
in Mighty Ducks did I?
- You didn't even like Gilmore girls.
I watched every show of that too.
(laughing)
I actually started that over.
It's such a good show.
That means it all the
left side of the house,
y'all win because I'm the winner.
But because I'm nice and it's my show,
so does the right side.
Everyone gets a prize.
All right it's American
Girls 35th birthday.
And they're re-introducing
the six original characters
that started it all.
Samantha,
Kirsten,
Molly,
Felicity,
Addie and Josefina.
They come in their original outfits,
authentic accessories,
and the first book in the series,
and everyone in the house seats is getting
a $300 gift card to American Girl Doll.
(audience cheering)
My daughter would freak out over that.
A big hand she tried
Lauren Graham everybody.
(laughing)
(audience cheering)
The Mighty Ducks Game
Changers is now streaming
on Disney plus.